Don good so we'll start with the actual
program now our first speaker is Noah
Stevens Davidowitz who's I guess that
Simon's now he's been a MIT postdoc and
he'll talk about his work with his PhD
adviser a dragon from New York
University on a topic of geometry so
geometry is the first word in that word
title and this is a work that was
breakthrough actually I think proves a
conjecture of Daniel's from a few years
earlier and the applications to computer
science are really just starting to
emerge there's been a few so far but
there will be many more we're sure so
yeah so thanks for the introduction
thanks for inviting me thanks to the
organizers Daniele I'm very excited
about this workshop really enjoying this
program in general so as Chris said I'm
going to talk to you about a sort of
purely geometric theorem which we call a
reverse Minkowski theorem
Daniel probably named it that it was
originally conjectured by Daniel and so
let's begin before I tell you what a
reverse Minkowski theorem is let me tell
you what minkowski's theorem is so
you've probably seen this already but
it's so beautiful you might as well see
it again
so allowed us to start from the
beginning is a discrete set of vectors
in n-dimensional space here's a
two-dimensional lattice you should
picture and dimensions if you can it's
specified by a basis B 1 through B n
linearly independent vectors we've all
seen this before I think see here's the
basis for this lattice and the last
itself is a set of integer linear
combinations so we get this nice
beautiful periodic set discrete periodic
set in n-dimensional space so usually if
you're a computer scientist the like the
least interesting lattice is is the N
actually for this talk the integer
lattice so the set of all points with
integer coordinates or the lattice whose
basis is like the identity matrix is
actually kind of the example that you
should think of
it's actually sort of geometrically most
it's like the extreme case for us so I
want you to keep Z n in mind sort of as
the talk goes okay so we're going to be
talking today about sort of the
fundamental or one of the fundamental
geometric questions about lattices which
is how many lattice points are there in
a ball of radius R so this will be my
notation for that I'll just write L
intersect BR all right now the of it so
for example this this ball has seven
points in it we're gonna be interested
in answering questions like this based
on certain properties of the lattice so
you might recognize like a special
version of this problem so a special
case is the question of what's the
length of the shortest nonzero vector in
the lattice right so from this
perspective that's just the the radius
of the this the smallest radius of a
ball that contains only one point or the
largest radius of a ball that contains
at least two points whatever you like
right so this is a special case but more
generally we can ask how many lattice
points are there inside a ball of given
radius and okay so this is going to be
interactive there's actually a pop quiz
so let's let's play with Zn let's ask
how many points are in a ball of radius
one in Zn you're only allowed to answer
if you've never thought of this before
huh n yes okay yeah I draw to you but
think of n five well you're gonna say it
- two times n plus one I think it's look
you might right so there are sort of all
the unit vectors and then there
occations and they're zero as well
okay slightly harder how many in a ball
of radius square root two
all right so these are the vectors that
have like two nonzero coordinates not
very interactive crowd um here's the
answer so this is four times n choose
two which is the number of ways to like
put plus minus ones and n coordinates
this is and then this is just the
previous guys so they're about N squared
more generally I won't torture you
because you guys don't seem into it but
for radius R strictly less than R
significantly less than square root n it
turns out that the number of points in a
ball of radius R is roughly and choose R
squared that's just because it's the
number of ways to put R squared ones in
n spots which is like n to the R squared
or I like to write things in exponential
so it's like exponential log n times R
squared and if you go to a ball of
radius root N or larger then you get
exponentially many points okay this is
just like a sort of nice fact to know
you know for cocktail parties okay so
that's Zn here's sort of a more general
way that we can count points in a ball
lattice points in a ball we can define
the determinant of the lattice so if
you're computer scientist it's nice to
know the determinant of a lattice is
efficiently computable so you can just
define it as the absolute value of the
determinant of the basis but that's also
kind of a rather ugly definition in the
sense that it depends on the basis of
the lattice a lot it's gonna have many
different bases and it's not even
immediately obvious I think that you'll
get the same answer so it's not even
clear that this is well-defined maybe I
take two different bases and I'll get
some different determinant but turns out
that there is like I think a much
prettier geometric definition so the
geometric definition
says the determinant is the limiting
value of the volume per lattice point
that you expect to see so I take the
limit as R goes to infinity of the
volume of a ball divided by the number
of lattice points in a ball sometimes
it's helpful to think of the inverse
here so it'd be like the limiting
density of the lattice so the number of
lattice points per ball so here's a
picture so we take a ball just like
before but we make it like a lot bigger
or like really a lot bigger and then use
vector graphics and the determinant is
as we go to as this radius of this ball
goes to infinity it's the number of
lattice points inside the ball let me
explain to you why this is true so the
reason is I can take my basis and the
basis defines what's called a
fundamental parallelepiped
in two dimensions just a parallelogram
easier to say and the parallelogram
tiles space right with respect to the
lattice so I can sort of assign to each
lattice point say the lattice point on
the bottom left corner of my
parallelepiped a parallelepiped and then
you can just sort of count the volume of
this ball in two different ways like one
way to count the volume of this ball is
just say it's the volume of the ball we
know how to compute that another way is
to say well the volume of the ball is
roughly the number of points inside
these parallelepipeds sorry the number
of parallelepipeds
times the volume of the parallelepiped
which is the determinant so you count
the volume in two different ways and you
see that these two quantities have to be
the same otherwise math breaks so what
you get out of this is that the
determinant is the inverse of the global
density of the lattice so it tells you
how dense the lattice is if you step
really far back but it doesn't tell you
at least not immediately sort of
anything about the density of the
lattice in small balls which is what we
usually kind of care about like for
example if we care about the length of
the shortest vector then we don't care
about the limit as R goes to infinity
so enter minkowski there is so he proved
in 1889 er he published in 1889 the
following theorem it says if the
determinant of the lattice is small then
the number of points in a ball of a
certain radius must be large so
Minkowski tells you that well if you if
you're limiting density is large then I
can promise that you'll have points in a
specific ball the specific radius the
radius need not go to infinity here and
so the specific numbers here so
Minkowski proved something well
incomparable to this but morally what he
proved is far more general than this
I just pro shows convenient numbers for
my talk but here I took a ball of radius
square root N and I promised you
exponentially many points and sort of
the reason that that makes sense
actually this is an absurdly good
approximation the volume of a ball of
radius half the radius that I chose is
about two to the N so what Minkowski
tells you is that you get the number of
points that you would expect right the
number of points that you would expect
is exactly the volume of the ball but
Minkowski doesn't give you exactly that
he gives you that up to a factor two in
the radius just check out so the way I
like to think about this or the way I've
come to think about this is that global
density implies local density right so
if I'm a very very large scale on my
lattice is dense then it must be dense
on a smaller scale so this theorem is
important here's my evidence of
important which does not show up very
nicely on this screen but yeah there's a
whole Wikipedia article
I'm damming it with faint praise it's
more important than that and just I
guess I kind of already said this but I
don't want to lie to anyone well
Minkowski proved is actually slightly
different daniele and the first talk of
the boot camp gave minkowski's actual
theorem I'm proving something slightly
different because it's more convenient
for my talk okay this is minkowski's
theorem and I'm gonna show you a proof
because it's so easy and it's B
oh except I'm just gonna cheat a little
bit instead of two to the end points I'm
gonna show you that there are two points
all right so one would be trivial to is
non-trivial this is usually the form in
which you see minkowski's theorem and it
turns out that the proof for two to the
endpoints is basically the same it just
requires a little bit of bookkeeping
okay so here's a proof with minkowski's
theorem
okay and good for cocktail parties so
we're gonna take our lattice and we're
gonna imagine a ball of radius square
root n over two and I'm going to assume
that minkowski's theorem is false so I'm
gonna assume that in a ball of radius
square root n I only have one point just
zero so in particular that means if I
place this ball around zero I guess this
is zero this ball won't touch any other
lattice points but actually this ball
has a radius square root n over two not
square root n so by triangle inequality
I can actually place a ball around every
single lattice point and none of them
will overlap at all right just by
triangle inequality because every
lattice point by assumption has to have
distance root n to any other lattice
point yeah and what's important about
this root n over two is that I guess I
told you something more accurate earlier
but all that's relevant is that the
volume of this ball is at least 1
strictly larger than one actually and
then again we're just gonna count volume
in two ways right so the definition of
the determinant tells you that you
expect to have for a lattice with
determinate most one you expect to have
at most volume one for every lattice
point and this gives you volume strictly
larger than one for every lattice point
that's a contradiction
I guess formally you can like take a
gigantic ball and count the number of
points inside and add up the volume of
these balls and compare it to the volume
of the ball but all you have to know is
that you get more than one unit of
volume per lattice point which is a
contribution to prove the two to the N
thing instead of thinking about balls
that are disjoint you think about balls
that like only intersect a little bit or
the number of balls that intersect in
any given
should be small but it's basically the
same person okay that's minkowski's
theorem
not seen it before now you have um now
I'm gonna tell you about reverse
Minkowski so remember in 1889 Minkowski
came and gave us this beautiful theorem
which says that the determines a lattice
is small then the number of points in a
ball is larger than two to the n enter
Daniel de dieu shoes sitting right over
there now at CWI and he has color
photographs at him he said in 2012
is there a converse of minkowski's
theorem and as far as I know it took
what is it 125 years or whatever 123
years I guess for for someone to have
this thought which I think I think is a
really good thought it's obvious in
hindsight which is the best kind of
thought so one way to phrase this is
does local density imply global density
remember minkowski's theorem was the
other way around it tells us who are
globally dense than we must be locally
dense Daniel's kind of asking if we're
locally dense must we be globally dense
I'm just going to tell you now I'm sort
of gonna play with the contrapositive of
this like men I'm gonna sort of rephrase
this in a few different ways so just be
sort of aware of that I think my first
rephrasing already happens here so let's
make a first attempt at making Daniel's
question precise well getting a question
that though is worthy of Daniel so first
we'll ask a dumb question
so if a lattice has more than two to the
endpoints in a ball of radius roughly
root n does this mean that it has to
have some all determinate here's our
first question you've never thought of
such things before you may answer
so the answer's no why is the answer no
it's because lattices can look like this
right are people following me okay
so right so what is this this is a
lattice of sort of dents in one
direction it has a very dense sub
lattice so let's just sort of make this
concrete let's say so s is some gigantic
number maybe it goes to infinity let's
say the distance between points along
this sort of dense subspace is one over
s and maybe the distance between these
sort of two rows is s squared the
determinant of this lattice is going to
be s so in other words I can make it as
large as I want and if I look at a ball
of radius R the number of lattice points
in a ball will be in this ball will be
at least R times s if I did that right I
think I did so this means I can make the
determinant as large as I want while
simultaneously having as many points in
a ball as they want but you know where
we're mathematicians or computer
scientists we don't give up so easily
right so we try to conjecture something
we find a counter example to our
conjecture what's the next conjecture
right the next conjecture is that the
counter example that you found is the
only counter example right so we can ask
a slightly more refined question which
is if a lattice has more than two to the
end points in a ball of radius roughly
squared n doesn't necessarily have a sub
lattice that has small determinants so
in a previous slide I showed you a
lattice witness has a sub lattice with
small determinants so formally a sub
lattice I take the intersection with
some sub space of the original liners so
daniel conjectured yes or you can check
sure something morally equivalent to
this statement morally equivalent and
the reason I'm talking about this well
it's still interesting even if it
weren't true but is because the answer
is yes and we've proven it so in other
words local density doesn't necessarily
imply global density that would be too
good there's sort of a trivial counter
example but it does imply global density
over some subspace
yeah okay so let's stare it this theorem
here here it is in all its glory or one
version of it so we say if all sub
lattices I'm sort of switching to the
contrapositive as I like to do we say if
all sub lattices have determined in at
least one then we have have at most two
to the end points in a ball where you
know I'm losing some gigantic Hudson in
the exponent which will ignore these
frames so let's compare this to makowsky
CR Mankowski tells us that if the
determinant is at most one then we have
to have many points inside a ball and
you'll see that these are kind of tight
ish I have to look at sub lattices but
we saw that that's kind of necessary and
there's a giant constant hiding there
but otherwise quite similar so let me
say a few things about this theorem so
first of all this is a toy version it's
just kind of the easiest one the most
natural one for me to write down we
actually prove bounds for any radius R
not just for radius square root n
actually what's more important is kind
of to bound the the Gaussian mass of the
lattice so you kind of want to maybe
this expression slightly to complicate
you want to bound the minimal s such
that you don't have e to the S squared
times R squared in a ball of radius R
for any R and the reason for this is
become slightly clearer but for the
bound that we actually want so this
theorem is like quite tight but for the
bound that we actually want we're
actually a little loose I guess it's the
point that I want to make I don't think
I'll even show you the bound that we
actually want but and when you state
this conjecture appropriately the worst
case should be Zn so again for this
exact statement the worst case is not Zn
but morally what is the end it's the
lattice that is tight for all these
constraints it's got as many a lot of
sub lattices as you can that have
determined it's exactly one so it
satisfies the constraint but it's tight
on all of them
so moral easy and should be the worst
case here and we think that it is
and maybe this is obvious from the fact
that we call this a reverse Minkowski
theorem but this is like very different
than what people normally study so in
particular what people are normally
interested in is things like sphere
packings and coverings and things like
that and these are questions about how
globally dense you can make a lattice
without making it too locally dense and
Minkowski steer and tells you that
you're packing can't be too great um
can't be too good
whereas we kind of say that all packings
are kind of okay in a vague sense
because of these sub lattices but
somehow like we're studying the worst
possible packings which usually don't
interest people very much but it turns
out that this has a number of
applications in fact many of the
applications predate the theorem there
due to Daniel and Oded so first of all
there's like a natural application for
the complexity of lattice problems and
then there are more subtle applications
like a natural application remember I
mentioned that the determinant is
efficiently computable so and we said
that if you have many points in a small
ball then there has to be a sub lattice
of small determinants so this in
particular implies that there's a
witness like an NP witness for the
statement that you have many points
inside a small ball so that's kind of
fun I think the reason Daniel was
originally interested in this was
because of a an approximation to the
covering radius due to Kannada and
lavash which Daniel will tell you way
more about on Friday so I'm just gonna
skip over that
it also has applications to Brownian
motion on flat tour I this is a
beautiful question due to Soloff cost he
asked if you have a random walk on a
torus you can talk about mixing time in
two different ways you can say when does
it converge in statistical distance and
when does it in curd converge point-wise
and yes are these two things the same
morally for like nice spaces they should
be the same and reverse Minkowski proves
that it's true the reason for this is
because somehow the flat torus is the
dual of a lattice so this is actually a
question about counting
points in a ball just extremely well
disguised and since Daniel oh no dad's
original paper we found a lot more
applications we found a counterexample
or a dead and Shahar found a
counterexample to a strong variant of
the polynomial free marriage a
conjecture due to Greene I don't think
anyone believes that this conjecture was
true but now we know it's false with
with Chris and the vide we showed new
proof systems for lattice problems
daniel is going to tell you about some
exciting connections with the the
slicing conjecture and with Barak and
aura Shapira we show connections with
minkowski's conjecture which is very
annoying because Minkowski appears too
often here okay
I'm gonna mention sort of briefly it's
good to kill the log okay is there a
lower boundary log I guess not yeah this
approximately is very so because I think
the audience is mostly composed of
computer scientists I'll tell you about
sort of elite a recent a pair of
applications are kind of the same thing
and which we show that you can use this
to find algorithms particular I want to
find algorithms I want an algorithm that
finds a non zero vector that is short
relative to determinants of the lattice
so we call this her meat SVP to
distinguish it from from SVP which is
the problem of just finding a short
vector relative to the length of the
shortest vector and the way that we do
this is we apply this gigantic heavy
hammer of reverse Mankowski to say look
if your determinant is small then you
have to have a dense sub lattice that's
what reverse Minkowski tells you and
then there are tons of algorithmic
techniques that only work over dense
lattices so we show that it's enough
have a dense sublattice and with this we
get some kind of exciting results for
example we get a 2 to the n over 2 time
algorithm for for her Mead SVP
we just tied up the poly log factors
lost half the audience I'll move on ok
let me talk about how we prove it
I think this proof has ideas that should
be better known in our ok so as a
spoiler
the proof is gonna go as the proof
sketch is gonna go as false I'm gonna
wave my hands a lot and then I'm gonna
bring out a heavy hammer so if so I'm
just gonna sort of warn you so he's
gonna sort of one warn you from the
outset this is going to be unsatisfying
I don't want you to expect a satisfying
conclusion where suddenly you understand
why this is true but I still think the
the proof techniques are worth doing in
the fact that we need to bring out a
heavy hammer at the end is just kind of
[Music]
so also
okay maybe some people haven't seen this
car okay I think it's from the New
Yorker okay so first I want to switch
the problem a little bit so remember
we're interested in counting the number
of lattice points in a ball of radius R
and this is kind of so this is like the
lattice point counting function and it's
kind of an ugly function right like in
particular two discrete so there's
really no way to think of it as like a
continuous function and it's typically
very hard to work with so sort of the
first thing that we do in fact this is
like step -1 is you switch to a much
much nicer function which I'll write is
Rho of L which is the Gaussian mass of
the lattice so in other words it's a sum
over all lattice points of the Gaussian
mass of each lattice point e to the
minus norm of the lattice point squared
and I tried to find my Gaussian t-shirt
today but I couldn't find it I have this
picture on a t-shirt but the point is
that the Gaussian mass is very much your
friend it's very very pretty
and why it's useful here well it's
useful here for many reasons but from
the perspective of this talk I guess the
reason that it's useful is because it
lets you get a handle on the number of
points in a ball in particular if there
are more points in a ball in a small
more small points in the lattice than
this value goes up right so if we want
to like upper bound the number of points
in the lattice in some bald and it
suffice is to bound this this guy yeah
so here's the theorem as I showed it to
you before here's an alternative version
to the theorem which is closer to it so
we actually call our verse Minkowski
theorem so instead of saying that the
number of points in a ball is bounded by
2 to the order n I tell you that the
Gaussian mass is bounded by 2 to the
order N and I'll give you a sec to stare
at this and just notice that this
statement implies that statement in fact
it goes in both directions that's not
immediate right so if I had more than 2
to the N points inside a ball of radius
square root n then my Gaussian mass
would definitely be larger than to the
order n yeah check out
[Music]
so we're gonna forget about this
statement we're only gonna be interested
in this statement and the way that we're
going to do this and I think like the
proof technique that I'd like to like
the computer science community to know
more about is instead of thinking about
one lattice we're gonna think about the
whole space of lattices which is very
unnatural for me like as a computer
scientist I kind of think of you know
math problems like computational
problems like you're given as input a
lattice and you want to prove something
about it but somehow it really really
helps here if you want to prove
something about a class of lattices with
a certain property it helps to think
about the whole class simultaneously for
a mathematician I think this is like
tremendously natural but I think at
least for me it wasn't particularly
natural so let's think of first the
space of all determining one lattices
and turned out that this is kind of a
hideous space it's well defined you can
make it well defined this is an artist's
representation so it's this disgusting
space it's well it's beautiful but it's
not compact there's a nice horror
measure on it but it tends to be
difficult to work with but luckily we
don't need the whole space of
determining one lattices we only need
the space of determinant one lattices
that satisfy our constraint from before
right so we only need the space of
determinant one lattices we're all sub
lattices have determinant at least one
it turns out that this is a very nice
space thanks for introducing me to it
it's called the set of stable lattices I
don't know why they're called stable but
this is a really nice space in
particular sort of I think the only
property I'll use a couple properties
the main property that we're gonna use
here is that this space is compact I
have a slide prepared in case someone
asked me what the topology is yeah
so I just don't know then welcome should
be the absolute and the indexed
multiplied by the determinant of the
model after so in this case so no good
lower dimensional sub lattices so think
of the lattice intersected with it with
a subspace yeah I mean I guess this
still holds for for Inc lattices but
it's interesting I mean they'd to
fulfill my lettuce but in the k2 program
and you all we have yet then it's not
interesting
exactly yeah so that is important so
when I say sub lattice think of a
lattice intersected with a subspace
right so if you remember my counter
example from before it was this lattice
that had this very very dense subspace
so that's what I'm talking about I'm
talking about the space of lattices
without very very done subspaces which
morally it's sort of the space of
well-behaved lattices like lattices that
have very dense subspaces are sort of
degenerate ok so the space of stable ad
is that this turns out to also be your
friend lots of friends and how we're
going to use this we're gonna return to
our question so we want to bound the
Gaussian mass over the space of stable
lattices we have a compact set here and
we have a continuous function we have a
continuous function so I don't know we
all learned in kindergarten first grade
when you have a continuous function on a
compact set it achieves its maximum
right so there's some global Maximizer
it's not necessarily unique or anything
but it achieves its maximum so there's
some lattice I'll call it L dagger that
is necessarily has the maximal Gaussian
mass in this whole set so now it's
suffice is to bound the massive L dagger
and what's really fun about this so I
sort of started asking a question about
a single lattice I want to know if a
lattice has this property does it have
small mass I switched to the space of
all lattices and then I use that to
switch back to a single lattice but now
my last is special right now I know
something about it and I can hope that
the fat
it's a global Maximizer really makes it
have very very nice properties that
allow me to bound it to mass more easily
yeah okay so here's how our dream proof
would go doesn't work or I don't know
how to make it work at least so I'm
gonna suppose that the mass the Gaussian
mass has no local Maxima over the set of
all determining one lattices so over
this whole space I'm gonna assume I'm
going to assume that this never happens
you can never have a peek if you if you
plot the Gaussian mass so this this
doesn't tap in if you like you can okay
it's not a convex function but you could
say if it were a convex function it
would have this property if that's the
case then you know second grade I don't
know you learned that the global
Maximizer has to be on the boundary of
the the set of stable lattices yeah you
lose everyone
I just need two stable ones but it's not
fun to think about local maxima and a
compact so I like to think about local
maximum open sense because you mean on
the compact set it would be yeah it sort
of depends what you mean by local yeah
you kind of have to consider like going
out of the boundary in order to define
local yeah yeah you can say sort of what
you're we there are no local maxima and
the relative interior yeah this is true
right so all I want to conclude from
this is that al dagger must be on the
boundary so all I would need to say is
that there are no local Maxima in the
interior I think some people call the
interior stable lattices of the full set
seventy stable lattices okay so now al
dagger lives on the boundary of this set
was it mean to live on the boundary of
the set remember how our sets defined
it's defined in terms of these many
inequalities and if you live on the
boundary of the set it just means that
one of these inequalities is tight it
means that there's some strict
sublattice
call it l prime whose determinant is
exactly 1 right
no complaints usually someone complains
here
okay so let's continue the dream proof
so let's assume that L dagger lies on
the boundary I'm gonna show you why
we're essentially done here's why we're
essentially done let me imagine my old
dagger so I live on the boundary
remember that means that I have some
sublattice L Prime
here's L Prime I know Prime has
determinant 1 which in two dimensions is
kind of boring it means you know that
this length is 1 but picture high
dimensions if you can and of course L
dagger itself has determinant 1 it's a
stable lattice so this height is also 1
and again picture high dimensions if you
can so here's what I'm going to do I
think it's a quite natural thing to do
I'm going to project so in other words
I'm going to sort of only write the
y-coordinates of these vectors and drop
the x coordinates so this is formally
I'm projecting orthogonal E and
projecting L dagger on to the space
orthogonal to L Prime it's just a tall
graphic and if your fancy you're right
this is L dagger a quotient L prime and
we have the following fact which I'm not
going to prove but if you know a little
bit about Gaussian mass it's kind of
immediate which is that the Gaussian
mass of L dagger is at most the Gaussian
mass of L prime times the quotient so
the Gaussian behaves nicely under these
quotient operations and if you know any
Fourier analysis this is positive
definiteness or this follows from the
fact that the function is positive
definite but anyway this is a basic fact
the next thing we have to observe is
that L Prime and L dagger quotient L
prime are both stable so the fact that L
prime is stable is is immediate right so
all the sub lattices of L prime are also
sub lattices of L dagger
they must have determined in at least
one because otherwise L dagger wouldn't
have been stable in the first place the
fact that the quotient is stable is less
obvious but it just follows from the
fact that L prime has determinant 1
simple proof so we combine these two
things together and we see that if L
dagger always lie in the boundary then
we can do induction all right so we can
we can reduce the case to two lower
dimensional problems and if you imagine
us continually doing this over and over
and over again eventually we'll just
reduce to Zn we're just reduced to two
the product of n one dimensional
lattices and once I get to one
dimensional lattice I don't know how to
do this projection thing anymore it
doesn't really make sense so we end up
saying that the the mass of L dagger is
at most the mass of the integers to the
nth power which is just the mass of the
integer lattice because it's a product
measure so this will be really fun
because it would show like the what what
the global Maximizer is it actually is Z
an I called it L dagger by accident but
it was the end the whole time in fact if
this proof were to go through you could
show that it's unique up to isometry is
it's really fun unfortunately it doesn't
work um sorry for wasting your time
particularly we don't know whether the
Gaussian mass can have local Maxima so
maybe we can have like these little
pimples in fact we think that it
probably can 24 dimensions the Niemeyer
lattices seem to be counter examples so
that's like very depressing although
it's not so bad particularly this proof
technique does work if you scale the
lattice down by a lot or scale it up by
a lot or here a lot squared n the
theorem is not as interesting in these
cases for various reasons but it's kind
of nice that it works so for these
functions I can actually show that Zn is
the unique global Maximizer yeah
it's really our proof technique oh I
think so the way that we prove this is
by studying the laplacian the second
derivative of this function and we want
to show that the second derivative is
effectively always positive
any when you write it you get some
expression in terms of the back you get
a sum over the lattice and if all your
vectors are long relative to your
scaling then every term is positive
probably a better way to see it is just
to realize that as you scaled well okay
as you scale up let's say the mass on
the shortest vectors becomes more and
more relevant right and the longer
vector is sort of go away and then like
morally it's kind of obvious of course
the end is gonna maximize the end you
know has 2 n plus 1 vectors of length 1
which is which is not optimal for stable
illnesses so I mean we can show it's
exactly optimal which is maybe a mile
and you get the other way by duality
maybe but I don't
I mean like what kind of world we live
in if it works um okay I used to say
that about these isms of local so
remember there is a little
bait-and-switch that I pulled where I
switch to only determinate one lattices
so as soon as you start scaling you'll
you'll no longer I've determinate one
lattice so you'll just leave the same
pound that right yeah you get
arbitrarily done flattest I mean I need
some kind of normalization yeah
yeah but I mean this is what kind of
idea you want to prove that like you can
just sort of do gradient ascent or
descent ascent and just get to Z and
eventually but it's C which i think is
kind of what you're saying but turns out
it probably doesn't work
okay so now we have to deal with the
unpleasant possibility that maybe our
global Maximizer is in fact a local
maximum as well which would be
unfortunate um so in other words we have
to deal with the possibility that El
dagger somehow lives inside this set or
a pierced heart and what's nice is that
if you're a local maximum then I can say
some things about you right so if el
dagger is a local maximum well then I
can do some calculus what does it mean
to be a local maximum well your
derivative is zero so here your gradient
is zero over some crazy space of
lattices and we can write that down we
can write what it means you're an expert
it means that the Gaussian mass is
isotropic I guess we can move to higher
derivatives as well but they don't
really seem very useful well to me but
hopefully we could try to use the
properties of this of being a local
maximum to bound the Gaussian mass
directly it turns out this is a very
good idea so let me sort of step back
and show you how that proof would go so
here's the slightly less training proof
it still doesn't exactly work but we're
getting closer so what I do what we do
is we can say if the global Maximizer is
on the boundary then we can bound the
mass by induction I showed you this
already right
so then we're done at the other hand if
the Gauss if the local Maximizer global
Maximizer is in the interior somewhere
then we can try to use the
characterization of local maxima to
bound the mass directly and either way
we get a bound on the mass of El dagger
which which was their goal so this is a
proof technique well ok was introduced
to me by Barak Weiss from a paper of his
with orisha pyrrha and I think it's a
really really beautiful technique it's
kind of similar to I think some stuff
that we're gonna see later in the
workshop so here's how our actual proof
goes
as much as I can show you um so a big
problem is that I don't know how to do
anything with these local Maxima of the
Gaussian mass so as I said very
unsatisfying the problem is that like we
don't know much about the discrete
Gaussian in general I mean it's been
around for a while but I think it's only
really been studied extensively for
maybe thirty years or so our solution is
to just sort of move to something that's
been studied by lots of smart people for
a really long time so we switched to a
convex body the specific convex body
that we switched to is the Voronoi cell
of the lattice so this is the set of all
vectors that are closer to zero than to
any other lattice vector and if you
think about it sort of morally if the
lattice scales up the Gaussian mass of
the lattice should go down and the
Gaussian the Voronoi cell gets bigger so
it's Gaussian mass should go up so
somehow this is kind of like the
reciprocal of the Gaussian mass of the
lattice being super duper hand wavy but
the nice thing is that the Gaussian mass
of convex bodies is very well-studied
far by your study then lattices so now
we use the same high-level proof
structure but now we work with this
function instead right so again we say
look if we live on if our global
minimizer now because I took a
reciprocal if our global minimizer lives
on the boundary then I know what to do
by induction if our global minimizer is
in the interior then I bound the mass
directly boundaries directly and the way
that we do that is we observe that if
the gradients zero then the Voronoi cell
has to be an isotropic Gaussian position
so the Gaussian distribution restricted
to the Voronoi cell is is the identity
matrix the covariance identity matrix
and then we bring out very heavy hammers
so we use the L position and the B
conjecture to say if you're an isotropic
Gaussian position then your mass is
bounded so
you showed us how to bound the mask by
indication you use some properties and
found it directly about this step okay
so we bound it directly because we show
that okay if you're a local Maximizer
then your gradient has to be zero or for
some space and we compute the gradient
and the gradient turns out to be just
the covariance of the Gaussian mass and
have ingredients here are corresponds to
being isotropic so having identity
covariance and then this is like a like
a well-studied problem the Gaussian mass
of of convex bodies in general when
they're isotropic
truncated yes it's the probability that
a continuous random variable continuous
Gaussian will land in no it's it's a
it's a proving conjecture yeah it's got
a terrible name as well yeah they think
I think B is bothering ya I'm not sure
but not check conjecture did yeah but
there's there's yet another heavy hammer
right the 2 to the N is from oh yeah ok
the theorem I've been showing you uses a
different heavy hammer instead yeah
at this level of generality I don't I
don't think we care for some reason my
animations do something weird now you
completely drop the fact that it said
where I saw the last yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and that might cost us to read log
n yeah yeah it would be completely
ported the problem to stuff that people
are very study those that's how I think
of it in hindsight at least
I think worth mentioning one part of the
magic which is that I mean you talk
about a point which is sort of the
critical point for let's say we assume
it's like the global minimizer of the
Gaussian mass of the war noise oh yeah
and I mean you don't really know
anything about minimizer's so you just
say it's a critical point yeah right
yeah and then by magic this turns into
when you switch to the convex geometric
side that you've magically put the
Voronoi selves in the position which
maximises seems to make it kind of
perverse that there may be local I guess
I don't know that there are local minima
of that particular function yeah yeah we
do do this like there's this weird flip
where in fact if you're a local minimum
of this function then you're a local
maximum of a different function
so I will actually show you the theorem
this is this is the actual theorem what
I showed you before is is also a theorem
but it's it's it's it was observed by
Daniel and it's very nice but it's
somehow not exactly what what we want so
this is the actual theorem it says if
you scale up the lattice by a log n
factor then the mass is at most two and
having mass at most two is very nice for
you analytically it means the dual is
smooth and just some remarks again so
this is the statement that where the
worst case should be Zn and that should
be just for all parameters T I should
just be able to write here a mass of T
times ya ya
and this is off by a factor of log n if
you think about it the point counting
that I showed you forever ago or you
guys didn't like the pop quiz there that
tells you that the right parameter here
for Zn is exactly squared lockers weird
log n times some constant maybe the way
I've formulated it and the point of this
is that it's really useful for Fourier
analysis like for example you can switch
to the dual and because you have this
very tight upper bound on the Gaussian
mass of the primal you can immediately
see the the dual lattice has mass that's
very very well constrained which is
pretty fun more generally we like smooth
lattices you know so we have these
algorithmic applications that you
smoothness all over the place yeah so
let me summarize so men Kowski gave us a
lower bound in the number of lattice
points in a ball based on the
determinant it's tied up to a constant
factor in the radius which I think I
said it has innumerable applications
Wikipedia page we proved is an upper
bound in the number of lattice points in
a ball based on determinants of sub
lattices
uh-uh and it's like reasonably tight ish
and it has some applications so pretty
good our proof technique is is do to
reappear and broccolis we said they
introduced it to me and it's this really
fun topological analytic approach that I
think should have a lot of other
applications I know to know that
mathematicians in the audience this is
like old news but I think week if you're
scientist don't use it enough um in
particular Daniel's going to talk about
this a lot more but we use it to show
well he's not gonna talk about mikowski
but we use it to show interesting
connections with the slicing conjecture
so you can just sort of replace the
Gaussian mass with your favorite
function on lattices and you know go
nuts so I'll leave you with some open
questions so the big open question I
think you know if you're ambitious is to
just prove that Z and the global
Maximizer of this beast for all t that
would be a lot of fun and I bet the
proof would be pretty and if you can't
do this maybe do it for for other
functions particularly if you know what
the Epstein zeta function is that's a
really nice candidate
[Music]
another thing that we'd like to do this
is from Daniel Deb's paper is we'd like
to be a little more fine-grained about
this so I realize that this is hard to
read but what we want to say here is
look minkowski's theorem you can
rephrase it in terms of sub lattices as
well you can say minkowski's theorem
tells you if you have a dense sub
lattice then the number of points inside
a ball should be at least the volume of
the corresponding dense sub lattice so
ball with the corresponding in the
corresponding dimension so it gives you
like this sort of hierarchy and you can
sort of write down sort of the bound
that Minkowski gives you which will be
this it'll be the K dimensional volume
or K is the rank of your sub lattice of
a ball of radius R divided by the
determinant of the ball you can ask how
tight is this and as far as we know
that's super tight but yeah we don't
know how to prove it I think that would
be pretty cool
um then you can ensure that we know that
that is false for convex bodies yes well
what about other norms so I think
Daniels gonna might say a little bit
more about this but the reason Daniel
originally conjectured this was because
he was interested in integer programming
right and in particular if you could
prove something analogous to reverse
Minkowski for other norms then you could
maybe get a two to the order n time
algorithm so if you could prove
something like reverse Minkowski for for
arbitrary norms and I think you'd get a
log into the end time algorithm it's not
I mean reverse Minkowski was a tool to
prove this kind of kind of low bus stuff
which we didn't talk about yeah and it's
the gentleman or inversion of that
there's stuff that you can prove in this
space that would give you fast
algorithms for integer programming which
is maybe for reverse Minkowski not so
much but
we were trying to pose a version of this
where you replace the ball by a general
complex body and that is like and then
the question was whether you could get
cn5 but that it turns out for general
convex bodies that's like n to the 1/4
at least yeah and and it's almost like N
or something but this however is is not
doesn't necessary say anything about the
conjecture you need for integer
programming it was just trying to
generalize this point counting thing to
what goes wrong there is like you can
just tailor your body to the lattice
because on this hold a bunch of lattice
points
so a few minutes for any more questions
is this basal state of lattices for
example what is it statement inside its
dimension
I guess it's full dimensional it's so
there's a horror measure on this face of
lattices and I believe Barak in an early
proved that that almost all lattices are
stable I think like the probability of
not being stables like n to the minus N
or something Tania like this so it's
it's like all of the lattices except for
the really weird ones
a random lattice won't be anywhere close
to the these constraints
no it's it's loose it should be real
again so root log n is tight for that n
and this is because of this like e to
the log n times R squared there so
everything is getting squared so that
log ends like our like a root log n so
we get is e to the log squared and as R
squared maybe that were confusing at all
but the short answer is we're off by
every day yes so actually so I showed
that for very small parameters and very
large parameters Zn is known to be the
global minimizer and like the the proof
from the book just goes through which is
a lot of fun it turns out that for n I
believe at most for my definition of
very big and very small overlap I see
you get everybody which is kind of fun
but I think it dies at N equals 5 it
might be like a fun exercise to try to
figure out what any small I might have
said something backwards somewhere but
yeah up to n equals 4 we know powerful
thing yeah it's not it's not one of the
largest
so just about the counter eggs and the
possibility of counter examples is so I
they're like is there anything we could
check on a computer by the end of the
day well what's what's the issue with
checking whether there's some things we
can't reason I can't example - what -
the whether something can be a global
local oh yeah yeah it would be cool if
someone computed the gradient of this
beast on the Niemeyer lattices I'll be
really fun we think that they're counter
examples so yeah there is like a super
easy thing that you can check and then
maybe will be fun to see what happens
with the Voronoi cell oh that sounds
harder but I don't know some of you
so there's a measure and there's a
natural measure it's the horror measure
so it's like the measure that's
invariant under linear transformations
and under that measure the space of
stable lattices is very very large I
mean the way to think about it is like
the lattices that aren't in the set of
stable lattices they're like high
dimensional analogues of lattices with
remarkably short vectors and like these
are rare like random lattices tend to
have all their short vectors of length
roughly verdad which is what you expect
okay so random lattices tend to have
sort of all their short vector is at
length they grew badin or something
because
[Music]
all right so we'll stop there and resume
at 11:30 for the next call
[Applause]